there is already extra security being
drafted in at the capitol buildings
the national guard on high alert this
attack has raised the threat level with
concrete barriers
now being placed around the entrance to
the complex
around the city flags have been lowered
to half-mast
after what has been another traumatic
incident for the police
the officer who was killed has been
named as william
evans who served in the force for 18
years
his friends have been paying tribute i
think the
the joy that uh billy found in being a
dad
the love he had for his kids uh he had a
terrific sense of humor
he was always playing pranks uh he
loved you know needling people and uh
you know telling jokes and making people
laugh
he had an infectious laugh and an
infectious smile
uh and he uh he just he just enjoyed
life he was a you know a terrific guy
the attack happened at two minutes past
one
on what was a quiet friday afternoon
congress was not in session
but there were staff and journalists
inside at the time
this video filmed by a bystander shows
the immediate
aftermath what happened here when a car
rammed two police officers before the
suspect
who was brandishing a knife was shot
dead has raised
searching questions about the
vulnerability of america's political
center
the investigation into the attack has
still not discovered
a motive but police say at this early
stage
that they do not think that this was
terrorism related
the attacker has been named as 25 year
old noah green from indiana
his social media reveals a man who was
linked to the black nationalist group
the nation of islam
his posts also suggest he was troubled
and struggling with what he called
afflictions
what investigators are doing now are
they are trying to fill in
the blanks as to who noah green also
known as noah
x is that is they want to interview
family members they want to interview uh
colleagues of his they want to take a
look at his social media
they want to take a look at his phone
perhaps he might have left the note he
might have told someone
there may be something that would
indicate why he carried out this attack
[Applause]
a security review was launched after
pro-trump supporters stormed the capital
on january the sixth
the chaos followed donald trump's false
claims that the presidential election
was stolen
this latest assault may lead to further
reinforcements
there are still 2 300 national guard
stationed in the city their mission is
now likely to be extended
with this serving as a disturbing
reminder that the capital
is still a target alex rossi
sky news washington